J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour, ravi de vous retrouver pour une nouvelle saison de Septante Minutes Avec.
Saison qu'on entame avec deux thématiques dont, encore une fois, tout le monde a entendu parler, mais rares sont les personnes qui connaissent les envers du décor.
On explore cette semaine les difficultés qui rongent les institutions judiciaires et les prisons en Belgique. Il y a la question budgétaire, évidemment, mais pas seulement, vous allez voir.
Pour vous donner une idée, au moment où j'enregistre cette intro, la presse vient de titrer sur un fait d'actualité qui illustre assez bien la situation, je pense.
Un homme avait été jugé en 2005 à vingt-cinq ans de prison. Il a pris la fuite pour un double meurtre. Il s'est ensuite fait pincer en Grèce en 2022, et puis extradé en Belgique.
Et arrivé ici, il a fait opposition à son arrêt et la chambre des mises en accusation a ordonné la tenue d'un nouveau procès.
Sauf que le dossier, qui a vingt-cinq ans,
est illisible et inutilisable parce que, en plus, voilà, des témoins, des enquêteurs qui sont décédés entre-temps, je cite
: « certaines parties du dossier papier ont disparu, d'autres sont illisibles, mouillées ou effacées en raison des infiltrations d'eau et de l'humidité dans le local où elles étaient conservées.
» Voilà, ça pose un petit peu le niveau. Ça vous donne une idée de là où on en est. Ça fait sourire, mais en même temps, c'est très grave.
C'est vraiment assez consternant. Vous allez voir que les exemples comme celui-ci ne sont pas rares et que tout ça pose question sur la qualité de l'État de droit en Belgique.
L'Institution fédérale des droits humains pointait d'ailleurs du doigt ce problème il y a quelques mois dans son rapport annuel, où il est fait mention d'une érosion manifeste de l'État de droit en Belgique.
On en parle avec mon invité, le remarquable Thierry Marchandise. Bonne écoute. J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec Thierry Marchandise. Bonjour.
Bonjour.
Pour ceux qui ne vous connaissent pas, vous avez été anciennement président de l'Association syndicale des magistrats.
Vous avez été pendant plus de dix ans procureur du Roi à Charleroi et vous avez également été juge de paix. Le grand public vous connaît sans doute parce que vous étiez procureur du Roi lors de l'affaire Dutroux dans les années 90.
Merci d'avoir accepté cette invitation.
Avec plaisir.
Alors, je le disais, donc vous avez pris votre retraite il y a quelques années, donc en 2020. Vous avez continué parallèlement à ça à être actif dans les médias comme aujourd'hui.
Vous avez continué à, voilà, être actif dans le circuit des conférences, des colloques, etc.
Qu'est-ce qui reste aujourd'hui chez vous ? Quelle est un petit peu votre motivation pour continuer à vous exprimer publiquement sur ces enjeux du judiciaire ?
En fait, j'ai réalisé que j'étais un passionné de justice.
Hein hein.
Ce qui fait d'ailleurs que les activités que j'ai encore aujourd'hui tournent autour de la justice.
Voilà.
Plus comme une fonction directe, mais je suis encore à la Commission des plaintes de la prison d'Eech. Je suis à la Commission de probation de Charleroi.
Ah oui, d'accord, oui.
Et à la Chambre de recours de la Société wallonne du logement qui touche quelque part aux questions de justice.
Donc ma présentation, déjà très complète, était en fait-
Elle est excellente.
Seulement à moitié complète. Très bien. Mais donc, on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour discuter un petit peu de l'état des choses, du paysage judiciaire en Belgique.
Un petit peu ce qui fonctionne et ce qui ne fonctionne pas. Parlez-moi un petit peu de votre expérience. Est-ce que votre expérience a globalement été positive lorsque vous étiez actif en tant que magistrat ?
Et voilà. Et sinon, à quel moment est-ce que vous avez remarqué peut-être un déclin ?
Mais moi, j'ai bénéficié des années où le personnel judiciaire était au complet. On a eu des périodes au parquet de Charleroi où il y avait moins de magistrats, mais on s'est rattrapé.
Et donc j'ai vécu des années judiciaires où on pouvait faire du travail convenable.
Ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui, de plus en plus, et l'exemple le plus flagrant, c'est le parquet de Bruxelles, où il y a toujours pas de procureur du Roi en titre depuis des années.
Ce sera bientôt le cas, normalement.
Oui, c'est ce qu'on dit depuis un certain temps.
Je suis naïf, je suis jeune.
Non, non, tout à fait. Mais ce qui est un peu effrayant dans les dernières années, c'est l'assèchement, l'assèchement du pouvoir judiciaire.
Et ça a commencé avec le ministre Geens, qui a refusé de
publier les places vacantes dans la magistrature. Et donc ça, c'était une rébellion du pouvoir exécutif à l'égard du pouvoir judiciaire, parce que la loi l'y contraint, le contraint normalement à publier les places vacantes.
Il ne le faisait pas pour des questions de budget, mais c'est à ce moment-là que les choses ont commencé à déraper.
Il faut se rappeler que en 2016, je pense, Jean De Cotte, qui était président de la Cour de cassation, disait qu'un État qui ne permet pas à sa justice de fonctionner normalement est un État voyou.
Voilà, on a beaucoup glosé là-dessus.
J'allais reprendre cette citation. Est-ce que vous le rejoignez aujourd'hui ? Est-ce que c'est votre constat aussi ?
Je pense qu'elle est plus vraie qu'elle ne l'était d'ailleurs déjà à l'époque.
Mh. Voilà, donc vous avez évoqué Koen Geens, donc, qui était ministre de la Justice pendant le gouvernement fédéral Michel, donc à partir de 2014.
Donc gouvernement marqué par une politique. Alors certains de mes invités appelleraient ça un assainissement des finances.
On va parler d'austérité.
Oui.
Pour globalement tous les services publics, y compris la question de la justice. Et voilà, et donc ça rejoint ce que vous expliquez à l'instant.
Donc vous évoquiez que les différents parquets en Belgique sont sous-staffés. À quel point exactement ?
Ça dépend des régions. Il y a des régions où ils sont à effectif complet. Il y a d'autres régions où c'est beaucoup plus compliqué.
Le grand parquet de Bruxelles est un parquet en difficulté, ça, c'est assez clair. Le parquet de Charleroi, actuellement, d'après les informations que j'ai, est aussi en sous-effectif de manière un peu chronique.
Ce qui pose alors la question de devoir choisir les affaires que l'on traite et celles que l'on ne traite pas. Ce qui est un choix qui ne devrait pas exister et qui, malheureusement, contraint alors à faire des choix qui ne,
qui sont contraires à l'intérêt du justicier, forcément.
Des choix qui sont presque politiques, en fait, quand on choisit de poursuivre certains cas et qu'on abandonne d'autres, c'est-
Alors, il y a normalement une politique répressive à avoir. Il y a une politique de conduite que le procureur du roi peut avoir sous le couvert des collèges des procureurs généraux.
Mais parfois, ce sont les priorités que fixe le collège des procureurs généraux, qui sont des priorités de politique criminelle.
Mais à certains moments, on est obligé, par exemple, en matière de roulage, d'abandonner les poursuites, ce qui est extrêmement gênant sur le plan— à la fois dans ce que ça rapporte à l'État et dans la configuration générale.
Les gens ont une impression d'impunité alors que simplement parce que les parquets n'ont plus les moyens de poursuivre.
Oui. Et donc plus les moyens, donc est-ce que c'est uniquement une question de budget ? Ou bien est-ce que, voilà, vous évoquiez les rapports compliqués entre l'exécutif et le judiciaire.
Est-ce qu'il y a un autre aspect en plus de la question budgétaire ?
Mais le rapport entre les pouvoirs remonte à l'affaire Agusta. Il faut rappeler quand même que c'est au moment de l'affaire Agusta que en Bel-
Une affaire de corruption
Une affaire de corruption politique. Et donc en Belgique, rappelons qu'il y a trois pouvoirs constitutionnels. Donc le pouvoir judiciaire est un pouvoir constitutionnel, ce qui n'est pas le cas en France pour l'administration de la justice.
Et donc les rapports entre les pouvoirs sont devenus compliqués parce que je pense la date charnière est bien l'affaire Agusta
à ce moment-là, parce que le monde politique a découvert qu'en fait l'impunité du pouvoir exécutif n'existait plus et qu'il pouvait être poursuivi dans la Cour de cassation.
Et donc ça, ça a agrippé le...
Et à l'époque même, un ministre flamand, dont j'ai oublié le nom,
rêvait de pouvoir faire de la justice une administration comme une autre, qui serait alors, comme on le sait, dans certaines administrations, un peu à la merci des pouvoirs politiques au-dessus d'elle,
ce qui n'a pas été le cas, heureusement.
Mais en mettant le pouvoir judiciaire dans un état de sous-investissement, on aboutit aussi à des formules qui aujourd'hui sont dangereuses pour le citoyen.
Mh. Donc un rapport presque de protection, de défense. Le politique qui protège les siens. Est-ce qu'on est un petit peu là-dedans ?
Alors, j'irai pas jusqu'à dire qu'il protège les siens, mais il empêche en tout cas la magistrature de remplir son rôle.
Du coup, ça a une incidence sur la confiance que le public peut avoir dans la justice.
Oui.
Et donc, c'est un cercle vicieux.
Mh.
Tant que les cadres ne seront pas remplis. On a fait plusieurs études de savoir quelle était la mesure de la charge de travail des magistrats, qui est un exercice quasiment impossible parce qu'il n'y a pas deux dossiers qui se ressemblent.
Et donc on est toujours à la fixation des cadres tels qu'ils ont été fixés par la loi. Mais quand le politique ne respecte pas la loi de ce côté-là, ben là, on rejoint une question qui se pose, qui est la question de l'État de droit.
Oui, oui. Oui, oui, qu'on aura l'occasion d'évoquer plus tard. Mais donc cette accusation de...
comme quoi ce serait un choix politique suite à l'affaire Agusta, c'est une accusation relativement grave, assez grave même, comme quoi c'est un choix politique que de favoriser le déclin du judiciaire en Belgique.
Qu'est-ce qui vous permet d'affirmer ça ?
C'est un constat qu'on fait qu'à partir de cette affaire-là, on a vu une dégradation des rapports entre la justice et l'exécutif.
La temporalité est une coïncidence, selon vous.
Tout à fait, mais je suis pas dans la tête des politiques, donc je ne sais pas le dire.
Mh, mh, mh. Très bien. Est-ce que... Voilà, certains évoquent aussi des aspects communautaires. Ce qui est frappant, c'est que quand on observe les ministres de la Justice depuis plus de vingt ans, ils sont tous des ministres flamands.
Je parle au niveau fédéral, bien sûr, tous des ministres flamands. Et ça s'est surtout partagé, ça s'est totalement partagé entre le VLD et le CD&V.
C'est assez frappant. Est-ce que ça a pu avoir des conséquences vis-à-vis de la justice d'un côté de la frontière linguistique par rapport à l'autre ?
Moi, je constate quand j'étais, par exemple, au conseil des procureurs du roi, les pratiques des magistrats, des procureurs du roi, des néerlandophones et des francophones n'étaient pas les mêmes.
Et on sent une différence d'approche des problématiques judiciaires extrêmement différentes.
En Flandre, si le patron dit qu'il faut faire comme ceci, on fera comme ça. En Wallonie, si le patron dit qu'on peut faire comme ça, on va se poser la question de savoir si le patron a raison, s'il n'y a pas d'autres manières de fonctionner.
Et je disais quand j'étais président de l'ASM, on devrait à la fois utiliser le fonctionnement efficace de certaines juridictions flamandes avec l'imagination des magistrats francophones.
En mélangeant les deux, on arrivera peut-être à quelque chose d'intéressant.
Mais donc là, vous parlez vraiment de presque la culture du travail, la culture des magistrats des deux côtés de la frontière linguistique.
Donc, pour revenir au fait que les ministres ont essentiellement été flamands, est-ce que ça a pu jouer ? Est-ce que le judiciaire a été favorisé d'un côté de la frontière linguistique par rapport à l'autre ?
Moi, je pense que oui. Je pense que oui. Des exemples, j'en ai pas des exemples précis, mais les nominations allaient sans doute plus vite en Flandre qu'en Wallonie.
Certains palais de justice ont été construits plus rapidement en Flandre qu'en Wallonie. Je pense au palais de justice de Namur et à celui d'Anvers.
Mais ça, c'est une analyse plus sociologique. Moi, je pense qu'entre le Nord et le Sud, des conceptions sociétales, judiciaires, philosophiques, de sensibilité politique sont en train de s'écarter de plus en plus. Et donc-
Et ça dépasse le judiciaire.
Et ça dépasse le judiciaire, je pense.
Hum, donc, alors, le gouvernement fédéral ne s'est pas encore formé. Évidemment, ils sont toujours en cours de négociation.
Mais tout indique qu'on se dirige à nouveau vers une politique d'austérité. On pouvait déjà s'y attendre pendant la campagne.
Est-ce que vous redoutez un assèchement encore plus important des finances et des budgets pour la justice ?
Ce serait une catastrophe. L'idéal, ce serait que la justice ait son propre budget, qu'elle gère elle-même et pas qu'il soit déterminé par d'autres pouvoirs que le sien.
Un juge parti, en quelque sorte.
Oui, mais en même temps, pour faire une politique, il faut pouvoir faire son budget. Sinon, vous ne savez pas vraiment faire une politique.
Mais pour revenir un instant sur la différence Nord-Sud, je me souviens que j'avais une amie qui était à l'OCAM, donc l'organe de coordination de la menace, qui était dirigée par un magistrat flamand.
Elle était magistrate francophone, elle était le numéro deux. Elle me disait à l'époque, ça date d'une dizaine d'années : « À l'OCAM, on n'écoute plus les francophones ». Donc c'était assez-
Explicitement.
Explicitement, c'était assez clairement dit : « On n'écoute plus les francophones ». Ce qui était impressionnant, mais qui confirme ce que je vous dis en termes de pays.
Elle le justifiait, elle l'expliquait ? Ou bien...
Oh bah, y a pas de justification, c'était comme ça.
Est-ce qu'elle comprenait ce choix ? Comment est-ce qu'elle le percevait ?
Non, c'est un choix incompréhensible. Tant qu'on est un pays fédéral, il est incompréhensible.
Je suis sûr que pour certains, c'est une évidence, mais effectivement...
Pas pour tout le monde.
Oui, voilà, c'est ça. Hum, très bien. Vous n'avez pas de sentiment, vous n'avez pas d'anticipation vis-à-vis de cette législature-ci, vis-à-vis du judiciaire ?
Vous n'avez pas d'attente particulière ?
Aucune. Ça dépendra de qui sera ministre de la Justice et voilà.
Oui, oui. Effectivement, quand j'avais soulevé ce dossier avec les différents politiciens que j'ai pu interviewer lors de cette dernière campagne, la question de la justice
revient souvent dans la campagne pour dire : il faut plus de justice, plus de police, plus de sécurité, sentiment d'insécurité, etc.
Et puis, quand on commence à parler des budgets, certainement pas question d'augmenter le budget, mais il y a cette idée de : on peut optimiser, on peut faire plus avec les mêmes budgets, voire avec moins.
Et arrive assez vite la question de l'informatique dans la justice. Et arrive assez vite cette image des vieux chariots, des piles de papier qui circulent dans les palais de justice.
Hum, est-ce qu'il y a un petit peu de vrai dans cette idée qu'on pourrait faire beaucoup plus avec les budgets actuels ?
Alors, sur l'informatique, moi, y a vingt-cinq ans qu'on parle d'informatisation de la justice. On a fait des études qui ont coûté très cher et qui n'ont rien apporté en termes d'efficacité.
L'informatisation est complexe dans la justice parce qu'évidemment, l'informatisation permet de simplifier les choses.
Or, en matière de justice, les choses ne sont jamais simples, elles sont plutôt complexes. Mais sur l'optimisation des budgets, je reviens un instant là-dessus, Michel Claes, qui a été juge d'instruction financier, disait-
Qui est à Défis, si je ne dis pas de bêtises.
Tout à fait. Et qui disait assez justement que si on investissait dans la criminalité financière, ça rapporterait à l'État des sommes faramineuses.
Oui, oui.
Alors, on peut se poser la question, mais ça rejoint une constatation quand j'étais au parquet de Charleroi. Chaque fois qu'on avait un ministre libéral à la Justice ou à l'Intérieur, en tout cas dans le gouvernement fédéral,
nous avions beaucoup plus de difficultés à monter les dossiers financiers et surtout les dossiers avec les évasions fiscales que si c'était un ministre plutôt de gauche, pour être un peu simple.
Et donc c'était intéressant de voir qu'on nous facilitait pas la tâche sur le plan de la recherche des infractions financières quand on avait un ministre de droite.
Ce que je disais il y a un instant, c'est que tous les ministres de ces vingt dernières années ont été CD&V-VLD.
Vous parlez de ministres de gauche ?
Mais le VLD, c'est un ministre de droite, un ministre CVP, c'est plutôt un ministre de gauche, mais c'est un peu caricatural.
Vous les placez au centre, le CVP, CD&V.
Oui.
Oui, oui. Ok, mais plus à gauche que le parti libéral, en tout cas. Très bien. Hum, très bien. Donc vis-à-vis de...
Voilà, ce que vous disiez sur l'État de droit en Belgique-
Oui.
Et comment celui-ci est impacté par la situation du paysage judiciaire. Hum, est-ce que vous avez des exemples qui vous viennent en tête d'État de droit blessé, impacté négativement par la situation qu'on connaît actuellement ?
Avant de répondre à votre question, je pense que vous êtes avec l'État de droit vraiment dans l'actualité. Je ne sais pas si vous avez vu que
le procureur général de la Cour de cassation a consacré sa Mercuriale de trente-cinq pages à l'État de droit en Belgique.
La bâtonnière de Bruxelles, qui a fait sa rentrée dans la Libre Belgique lundi, parlait elle aussi de l'État de droit.
Le président d'Avocats.be, maître Gotaux, un Liégeois, parle aussi de l'État de droit. Et la présidence belge au Conseil de l'Union européenne avait dans ses projets l'État de droit.
Donc c'est une inquiétude largement partagée.
Largement partagée, surtout qu'en Europe, on a en tout cas deux pays, je pense à la Hongrie et la Pologne, où la question de l'État de droit est vraiment une question d'une brûlante actualité.
Une situation assez tragique.
Et même tragique. Alors l'État de droit en Belgique, alors on n'a pas de définition précise et consensuelle sur l'État de droit.
Moi, j'emploie une définition relativement simple, c'est que l'État de droit, ça signifie que personne n'est au-dessus des lois.
Ça, c'est la règle pour moi qui me paraît simple. Il y a peut-être des petites nuances en matière diplomatique.
Par exemple, un diplomate ne peut pas être attrait en Belgique, sauf pour les contentieux de roulage, mais sinon, il peut éventuellement être expulsé du pays s'il y a un problème.
Mais donc l'État de droit, c'est ça, c'est personne n'est au-dessus des lois et le respect des lois est assuré par le pouvoir judiciaire.
Alors, il y a plusieurs exemples. Je pense que l'État de droit
est mis en péril d'abord par, je reviens à l'assèchement des moyens financiers pour la justice,
dans la mesure où la justice ne sait pas remplir son rôle, que le citoyen a moins confiance dans la justice et qu'il s'adresse à des voies détournées plutôt qu'à la justice pour
régler ses problèmes.
Ça, c'est une première chose. Deuxième-
Vous avez des exemples de voies détournées dont vous avez pu entendre parler ?
Ben, il y a des règlements amiables sur le plan commercial, par exemple, des gens qui passent le,
le tribunal de l'entreprise en prenant des arrangements avec des médiateurs qui payent d'ailleurs terriblement cher, beaucoup plus cher que la justice, parce que ça va plus vite et c'est plus efficace.
Donc voilà un exemple. Un autre exemple qui est dramatique, c'est que l'État belge ne respecte pas les décisions de justice.
En matière, par exemple, d'accueil des étrangers, migratoires, il y a des décisions qui ont été prises qui ne sont pas respectées.
Puis un exemple, quand un ministre, je pense à Theo Francken, se permet de critiquer une décision de justice, c'est inimaginable.
Oui. Ça va à l'encontre de la séparation des pouvoirs.
Tout à fait à l'encontre de la séparation des pouvoirs. Donc voilà, ça fait pas mal d'exemples, des condamnations de l'État qui ne sont pas suivies d'effet.
Quand l'État est condamné à des astreintes, les résultats ne suivent pas. Et alors, on peut penser à tout l'État de droit dans le monde pénitentiaire.
Oui, on va en parler plus tard.
On va en parler plus tard.
Également une condamnation de l'État belge à ce niveau-là.
Oui, tout à fait.
Oui, oui. Mais donc, pour continuer sur l'État de droit. Donc, vous disiez personne au-dessus des lois. On évoquait il y a un instant le fait que
les magistrats, les procureurs doivent parfois, souvent, malheureusement, faire des choix, choisir les dossiers qu'ils vont abandonner, qui vont parfois dépasser la, voilà,
qui vont traîner pendant plus de vingt ans et qui ne pourront plus être traités par le tribunal.
Donc est-ce que c'est là un des exemples de l'État de droit blessé et impacté en Belgique ? C'est-à-dire que certains dossiers vont juste finir à la trappe parce que pas assez de staff, pas assez de budget.
Pour moi, c'est le plus dramatique effet négatif de l'absence d'État de droit en Belgique sur ces questions-là.
Il faut savoir que si vous passez la frontière avec la Hollande, qui n'est quand même pas tellement éloignée de chez nous, en Hollande, il n'y a aucun procès pénal qui ne peut être introduit au-delà d'une année.
Donc quand une affaire pénale naît, elle doit être soumise au tribunal dans l'année.
Alors, si vous comparez ça avec les délais dans lesquels les affaires viennent dans les tribunaux correctionnels et devant les cours d'appel, on est en Patagonie, hein.
Oui, oui. J'ai un exemple dans mon entourage, une personne qui avait déposé plainte, et puis ça a mis effectivement deux ans, deux ans et demi pour être traité, donc en première instance en pénal.
Et puis le temps que ce soit traité, et puis le temps que ce soit renvoyé. Et puis il y a toujours l'histoire de : c'est presque mon chien a mangé mon devoir, je suis malade, donc on reporte.
Donc ça, c'est encore un petit peu plus reporté à plus tard. Et puis on arrive, dans le cas de cette personne, on est arrivé à la situation où
le dossier a dû être reporté pour les raisons qu'on évoque, voilà, aujourd'hui, hein, le manque de ressources, manque de budget.
Et effectivement, on arrivait au-delà du délai de prescription, vis-à-vis du jour où le dossier serait présenté en deuxième instance en cour d'appel.
Donc effectivement, c'est tout à fait concret. C'est des choses qu'on constate au jour le jour.
Et peut-être, l'image que vous venez de donner, on peut y voir deux aspects. Il y a, comme dans toutes les professions, il y a des meilleurs, des moins bons.
Il n'est pas impossible de tomber parfois sur un magistrat paresseux qui est très content de pouvoir reporter l'affaire parce qu'il y a toujours un prétexte pour la reporter.
Et à côté de ça, vous avez des magistrats qui travaillent le week-end compris, pour essayer d'arriver au bout de leur travail et puis qui finissent par avoir un problème de burn-out.
Voilà, j'allais dire, c'est un problème qui ronge la profession.
Voilà, donc ils sortent du cadre, ils sont toujours dans le cadre, mais ils ne remplissent pas les fonctions.
Et donc globalement, la profession subit ces désagréments-là.
Vous évoquez le fait qu'il y a des choix qui doivent être faits. Donc, vous évoquez à l'instant l'idée que des dossiers plus simples à traiter que d'autres.
Et vous évoquiez également tout à l'heure l'idée qu'il y avait une charte à suivre pour choisir les dossiers auxquels on pouvait donner priorité.
Vous pouvez m'expliquer un petit peu ?
Le procureur du Roi définit la politique criminelle de son arrondissement. Donc c'est lui qui fixe. Et en général, ça se fait évidemment en consensus avec les responsables, ce qu'on appelle les premiers substituts.
Et on définit pour chaque type d'infraction. D'ailleurs, le rôle du procureur du Roi est aussi de structurer son parquet en fonction des activités criminelles.
On développe une section financière, on développe une section de criminalité organisée, on développe une section de roulage, etc.
En fonction de la réalité.
Voilà. Et d'ailleurs, en ce qui concerne Bruxelles et les- La situation assez tragique, les tueries qui ont lieu relativement régulièrement en rapport avec le trafic de drogues.
Il y a, je pense, des tribunaux qui ont été montés spécifiquement pour traiter ces dossiers-là.
Mais normalement, dans un système normal, avec un procureur du Roi en fonction, c'est lui qui traite avec le président du tribunal l'organisation en fonction des actualités judiciaires, criminelles.
C'est lui qui négocie avec le président l'ouverture de chambres particulières pour des conceptions particulières. Mais comme il n'y a pas de procureur du Roi à Bruxelles, c'est très compliqué pour le moment.
Et c'est— pour moi, c'est simplement scandaleux.
Alors, on n'a pas encore parlé du Conseil supérieur de la justice, qui est donc un organe relativement important dans le paysage.
Un audit a été demandé par celui-ci. Qu'est-ce que ça a donné ?
Un audit sur le— Il faut rappeler que le Conseil supérieur de la justice est une idée de l'ASM. Donc, on est assez fiers parce que— qui est né dans les affres de l'affaire Dutroux.
C'est un des bénéfices de l'affaire.
La fameuse marche blanche.
Tout à fait. C'est un bénéfice de l'affaire Dutroux. Ce qui est une très bonne chose parce que ça-
On peut peut-être réexpliquer un petit peu ce que c'est.
Oui, le Conseil supérieur de la justice, c'est lui qui, aujourd'hui,
procède aux nominations des magistrats. Le ministre n'a plus de choix de nommer ou de ne pas nommer, dans la mesure où c'est le Conseil supérieur qui identifie le meilleur candidat pour chaque poste.
Et donc, il est composé d'une part d'une commission de nomination. C'est eux qui gèrent ça. Il y a aussi une seconde commission qui est plus une commission réflexive sur les questions de justice.
Et notamment, c'est elle qui fait les audits.
Oui.
Mais vous parlez d'audit, je pense que moi, j'ai connu deux audits du Conseil supérieur sur la Cour d'appel de Bruxelles qui donnaient des pistes
très sérieuses d'amélioration du fonctionnement de la Cour d'appel de Bruxelles, qui est en état
de décrépitude depuis des années.
Et en fait, ces deux études n'ont rien abouti au système— une modification de la Cour d'appel de Bruxelles. Donc ça pose question.
Est-ce qu'il y a une volonté politique de répondre aux— parce qu'il y avait des suggestions qui étaient faites par le Conseil supérieur, mais on n'en a pas tenu compte.
Donc, en une phrase, c'est uniquement pour les questions de budget ?
Mais le procureur général de Bruxelles, dans sa Mercuriale, vient d'encore tirer la sonnette d'alarme dans la mesure où il y a beaucoup d'affaires qui vont aller devant la Cour d'assises de Bruxelles.
Et une Cour d'assises, ça mobilise un magistrat de la Cour d'appel et deux juges de première instance. Ça veut dire que pendant un certain temps, des juges sont
sortis du tribunal et donc ne peuvent pas remplir les fonctions habituelles du tribunal de première instance.
Donc ça, c'est une question qui se soulève depuis un certain temps et qui devrait pouvoir éventuellement avoir une solution.
On évoquait là également le fait que le parquet de Bruxelles ne disposait pas d'un procureur du Roi depuis, depuis...
Alors, ce serait lié— c'est lié apparemment à BHV, au fait qu'il y ait une session à ce moment-là et que
suite à une décision de la Cour constitutionnelle, voilà, la situation par rapport à la présence ou non d'un procureur du Roi au sein du parquet bruxellois
était un petit peu ambiguë, ce n'était pas très clair.
Et puis on a eu donc le— suite à l'attaque, à l'attentat du 16 octobre 2023, et donc ce fameux— la question de ce fameux dossier qui avait disparu, qu'on n'arrivait pas à retrouver, qui était dans une armoire et puis qui n'y était plus.
Et puis, voilà, il y a eu un audit mené par le Conseil supérieur de la justice à ce sujet-là. Ça a fini enfin, suite à cet attentat, à déboucher sur,
un texte voté à la Chambre des représentants pour clarifier la situation vis-à-vis du procureur du Roi.
C'est pour ça que je disais en début d'interview que normalement, il est annoncé que d'ici la fin de l'année 2024, peut-être début 2025, il y aura enfin un procureur du Roi à Bruxelles.
Mais vous n'y croyez pas, visiblement.
Je pense que les magistrats du parquet de Bruxelles, qui n'ont toujours pas de procureur du Roi, n'en ont rien à faire
de la complexité institutionnelle qui aboutit à ce que vous avez décrit, qu'on ne parviendra pas à expliquer à un magistrat français.
Il ne comprendrait absolument pas comment les choses peuvent se passer comme ça.
Tout ça est très belge.
Voilà.
Ma question, c'était-
Mais quand vous parlez de fin 2024, 2025, ça fait quand même quelques mois qu'on me dit que : « On a trouvé une solution, mais la solution, elle devrait encore demander six mois.
» On ne comprend pas pourquoi il faudrait six mois.
Et alors, pour revenir, parce que c'est à partir de ce que vous dites là,
le Conseil supérieur et la magistrature proposaient que quand quelqu'un arrive à la pension, que six mois avant
son départ à la pension, on puisse déjà ouvrir la place vacante, déclarer vacante la place,
ce qui permet à la procédure de désignation, qui dure de fait quatre, cinq mois devant le Conseil supérieur, d'aboutir à ce que quand le magistrat arrive à sa date de pension,
son successeur soit déjà opérationnel et puisse prendre la fonction immédiatement.
C'est choquant que ce ne soit pas déjà le cas.
Mais évidemment, mais c'est une question de bon management. Le management, on ne peut pas en discuter, parce que le monde politique et le management, c'est une question...
C'est incroyable. Mais ce qui est incroyable, c'est qu'aujourd'hui, on publie les vacances de places quand le magistrat est parti.
Et donc, on perd nécessairement six mois. Il y a six mois de trou, au moins six mois. Pour autant qu'on publie la vacance.
Si on ne la publie pas, ça fait parfois des années.
Et donc cette suggestion du Conseil supérieur de la justice faisait suite à un dossier en particulier ?
Je pense que c'était la règle, je dirais, dans les années septante, soixante, septante. C'est comme ça qu'on fonctionnait.
C'est une règle basique de bonne gestion publique. On peut se poser la question de savoir pourquoi les règles basiques de bonne gestion publique ne sont pas appliquées.
Par les politiques aujourd'hui.
Fini par être oublié. Hum, j'allais vous demander vis-à-vis de l'État de droit, donc en Belgique, la situation qu'on connaît, est-ce qu'il y a d'autres pays
que vous enviez, que vous percevez comme étant beaucoup plus sains vis-à-vis de leur État de droit, vis-à-vis de leur paysage judiciaire ?
Est-ce que vous avez en tête des exemples ?
Mais en justice pénale, je pense à la Hollande, dont je parlais déjà tantôt. Parce que ce système fonctionne et ils n'ont pas une criminalité plus élevée que la nôtre, au contraire.
Et je dirais même qu'en Hollande, par exemple, le système pénitentiaire fonctionne beaucoup mieux que le nôtre. Ils n'ont pas de surpopulation carcérale, ils n'ont pas les problèmes de violence institutionnelle qu'on connaît dans la prison chez nous.
Donc peut-être que pour moi— alors c'est paradoxal parce que la Hollande est tout de même un pays à la langue proche de celle des magistrats néerlandophones et des politiques néerlandophones.
Et ça m'étonne que le monde politique néerlandophone n'aille pas voir en Hollande comment les choses se passent pour s'en inspirer.
Mh. Oui. Différence culturelle assez marquée quand même, mais effectivement, on pourrait-
Une proximité de langue, en tout cas.
Oui, oui. Les Pays-Bas. D'autres exemples qui vous viennent en tête ?
Non. En matière pénitentiaire, je sais que, par exemple, mais là, on va un peu plus loin, c'est le Québec. Le système pénitentiaire québécois fait qu'ils n'ont pas les problèmes pénitentiaires que nous avons en Belgique.
Et, oui, l'Espagne ne fonctionne pas trop mal non plus. En France, le système français est un peu particulier parce que les parquets sont quand même très fort soumis au pouvoir politique.
Mais, oui, je n'ai pas d'autres exemples où la justice fonctionnerait bien mieux que la nôtre.
Oui. J'ai l'impression qu'effectivement, il y a souvent des problèmes à pointer un petit peu partout qui sont à chaque fois assez différents.
Je pense à— voilà, on parlait de personnes au-dessus des lois. Je sais qu'en Amérique, c'est une question qui se pose beaucoup en ce moment suite à une décision de la Cour suprême.
Hum, très bien. Je vais revenir sur un dossier qu'on a rapidement évoqué un petit peu plus tôt, qui est la question de l'informatisation.
Alors, c'est— bon, vous avez expliqué que c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ce qu'on pourrait soupçonner. Parlez-moi un petit peu de à quel point les magistrats dépendent du papier
et quelles sont les tâches où vous pourriez imaginer une informatisation.
L'informatisation est— elle est entrée dans nos mœurs et nous, on la trouve partout. C'est peut-être plus la question de la digitalisation qui est problématique dans la mesure où on va vers une uniformisation
des processus, alors qu'en réalité, la matière justice est une matière complexe.
J'en parlais à propos de l'évaluation de la charge de travail des magistrats. On a essayé avec l'informatique d'essayer de trouver, mais on s'est rendu compte que c'était quasiment impossible parce qu'il y a des dossiers complexes.
Alors les dossiers complexes, ce n'est pas le nombre de pages de dossiers, mais ça peut être simplement la matière qui est extrêmement complexe.
Donc, l'informatisation, moi, je l'ai connue à la fin de ma carrière de juge de paix, où on nous installait un programme informatique, un programme informatique qui avait déjà dix ans d'âge.
Donc, il était déjà obsolète par rapport à l'évolution des produits informatiques. Et donc, à l'époque, moi, je rédigeais encore mes décisions à la main.
Et puis, tout doucement, on a commencé par les rédiger sur le clavier, le greffier corrigeant éventuellement le texte que le juge lui proposait.
Mais c'est le support logistique qui n'est pas toujours à la mesure des résultats qu'on voudrait bien avoir de ce support logistique.
Ça ne fonctionne pas comme ça devrait fonctionner.
Ça ne fonctionne pas. Alors, il y a peut-être, évidemment, on dit toujours que les juristes sont rétifs aux chiffres.
Il y a peut-être une partie de ça, une partie de magistrats pour qui l'informatisation est complexe et la compréhension de l'informatisation est complexe.
Mais on aboutit par exemple à des décisions politiques qui sont prêtes d'être prises. C'est qu'aujourd'hui, on n'envoie plus les décisions judiciaires
par huissier au domicile des personnes en remettant un exemplaire papier de la décision de justice.
Aujourd'hui, vous devez aller chercher dans le close votre décision. Et pour vous-
Spontanément.
Spontanément, vous devez faire ça. Alors, pour ceux qui se débrouillent bien avec la matière informatique, ça peut encore aller, mais on imagine que pas mal de gens ne parviendront pas à trouver la décision.
Ça pose des questions par rapport aux délais dans lesquels on peut interjeter appel d'une première décision. Là aussi, tout ça est complexe.
Et donc je pense que, il y a eu pourtant des groupes de travail qui ont fonctionné entre magistrats et informaticiens et politiques.
Mais on est toujours, me semble-t-il, un peu en retard.
Mh. Ce qui moi, personnellement, m'a toujours surpris, c'est que, donc on peut tout à fait entrer au palais de justice, par exemple ici à Bruxelles, et voilà, être assisté à une audience, à un procès qui a lieu.
Donc c'est tout à fait à portes ouvertes. En revanche, si je vais sur le site internet du Moniteur belge ou des différentes instances judiciaires,
c'est pas possible de juste dire : « Je serais intéressé de voir la décision qui a été prise la semaine dernière au Palais de justice bruxellois.
» Il y a une espèce de non, il faut être là en présentiel, sinon on n'a pas accès aux informations.
Alors, l'exemple que vous donnez, il y a évidemment le fait que les audiences sont publiques, ça, c'est indispensable.
Donc n'importe qui peut assister à une audience et la personne pourrait assister au prononcé de la décision. Maintenant, une fois que la décision est prononcée, elle ne peut pas être à disposition de tout le monde.
Pour quelle raison ?
Parce que c'est une décision personnalisée qui ne concerne qu'une personne.
Oui. Je pensais par exemple au pénal où on pourrait imaginer des précédents.
Au pénal, la seule manière d'avoir un résultat d'un procès pénal, c'est éventuellement si la presse a assisté, elle peut donner le résultat.
Oui.
Parce qu'il a été prononcé en audience publique.
Et aujourd'hui, au regard de la justice, tout le monde avec un compte Facebook, un compte Twitter regarde la presse. Donc tout le monde pourrait assister à un procès et en parler publiquement sur Internet.
Oui, oui, mais il faut voir d'abord, faut voir l'intérêt de la chose. Et puis, il faut voir aussi la protection de la vie privée, hein.
Le RGPD s'applique à tout le monde aussi.
Mais donc, je ne parviens pas à réconcilier cette idée que ce soit à portes ouvertes, que l'information soit disponible à tout le monde si on est là le jour J, mais que le lendemain, ça devient personnel, privé, personnalisé, RGPD, etc.
C'est la complexité des choses.
Oui, mais vous savez m'expliquer un petit peu ?
Ah, je ne sais— non, je ne saurais pas vous dire plus que ce que je viens de vous dire.
Ok.
Non.
Bon ok. Qu'est-ce que vous rêveriez de voir concrètement en tant qu'amélioration vraiment logistique au sein du paysage judiciaire, au sein des différents parquets ?
Il y en a tellement. Il y en a tellement, il faudrait... Il y a eu, un moment donné, un G mille, un G, oui, G mille sur la politique, je crois.
Il faudrait un G mille sur la justice. Il faudrait partir presque, il faudrait— c'est un rêve, évidemment, puisque vous me demandez que je rêve, je rêve volontiers.
Il faudrait partir d'une feuille blanche en disant : « Une justice pour quoi faire ? » On partirait de l'idée une justice pour quoi faire.
Puis on pourrait construire tout un système.
Repartir de base.
Repartir d'une base et construire peut-être un schéma tout à fait différent. Parce qu'il y a à apprendre dans différents pays.
Vous parliez des États-Unis où là, les magistrats sont élus et donc le système ne fonctionne pas moins bien qu'un système où les juges ne le sont pas.
Donc ça pourrait être aussi une question qui serait ouverte. Mais partir d'une justice pour quoi faire ? Une justice pour qui ?
Et mon rêve aussi, c'est de remettre le justiciable au centre du débat. Parce que la justice, elle ne sert qu'au justiciable.
Or, on a souvent l'impression que l'organisation judiciaire est faite pour des questions budgétaires, pour des questions éventuellement de personnes, alors que la personne principale dans la justice, c'est le justiciable.
On a beaucoup parlé de l'impact de l'exécutif, du politique, des questions budgétaires qui affaiblissent le paysage judiciaire en Belgique.
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas aussi, parallèlement à ça, une introspection qui est possible, que les différents parquets, que les différents magistrats pourraient remettre en question vis-à-vis de leur façon de travailler ?
Je pense que c'est une bonne question que vous posez. Je pense que l'introspection, elle serait nécessaire.
Elle a été rendue possible à un moment donné quand on a parlé de l'évaluation des magistrats,
ce qui était une manière intelligente de se dire : eh bien— cette forme d'introspection, puisqu'on vérifie à l'intérieur de la magistrature si les gens fonctionnent bien.
Le problème, c'est que on a fonctionnarisé ce système qui fait que même les mauvais magistrats ont des appréciations favorables.
Voilà, donc ça, c'est dommage. On a raté une chance qui était celle de faire une évaluation intelligente, parce qu'une évaluation, ce n'est pas seulement pour démolir quelqu'un.
Ça peut être au contraire de permettre à un magistrat qui ne fonctionne pas de manière tout à fait optimale de trouver une amélioration dans son fonctionnement.
Une défiscalisation.
Comme une évaluation est en principe, devrait en principe être à la fois positive et négative s'il le faut, mais il ne faut pas partir de l'idée que l'évaluation est nécessairement négative.
Oui. Mais donc une évaluation qui resterait, entre guillemets, privée, qui resterait—
Oui, qui améliorerait le fonctionnement.
Le Conseil supérieur de la justice et le magistrat en question. Oui, oui. Ok. Donc c'est, voilà, ça a été mis en place, mais ça pourrait l'être beaucoup mieux.
Oui, ça ne fonctionne pas vraiment.
Oui, oui. D'autres exemples qui vous viennent en tête de...
Non, je ne... On rêve d'un ministre de la Justice qui ouvrirait les portes et les fenêtres pour dire : réfléchissons ensemble.
Et peut-être aussi, un rêve, c'est que les pouvoirs se parlent entre eux mieux qu'ils ne le font maintenant. Parce que le judiciaire, par sa jurisprudence, a une influence sur le législateur.
Mais législateur, on a eu l'exemple de la réforme du code pénal qui a été compliquée parce qu'il y avait un contexte politique qui faisait qu'il n'était pas question de changer des choses.
Et l'idée principale du côté de la commission de réforme, c'était de considérer que la prison n'est la solution, la dernière solution auquel le juge pénal doit penser.
Ce qui est contraire d'aujourd'hui. Aujourd'hui, la première peine auquel on pense, c'est la prison.
Et dans la réforme du code pénal, on expliquait qu'il fallait réfléchir à d'autres formes, des formes alternatives de sanctions et de n'envisager l'emprisonnement que comme solution ultime s'il n'y en avait pas d'autres.
Il aurait fallu plus de dialogue entre le—
Je pense qu'il aurait fallu beaucoup plus de dialogue.
Oui. Ça ne vous plaît pas cette idée de mettre la prison un petit peu en arrière-plan et...
Si, si, au contraire, c'est ce que l'ASM propose depuis quarante ans.
Ok. Donc dans ce cas-là, ça va. Mais il y a d'autres exemples où il aurait fallu plus de dialogue.
Oui, je pense. Il y a, au moment de l'affaire Dutroux, la commission sur les dysfonctionnements de l'enquête Julie et Melissa, c'était un moment qui aurait été intéressant de vérifier, le—
de parler entre le monde judiciaire et le monde politique à ce moment-là, mais ça a été une occasion complètement ratée pour des questions politiques, me semble-t-il.
Vous parlez de la prison, parlons-en.
Oui.
Donc la Belgique a été condamnée en raison de la surpopulation carcérale dont il est question en Belgique, condamnée à la baisser à 110 % avant de tout faire pour la baisser à 100 % le plus rapidement possible.
Des prisons ont été déconstruites et sont toujours en construction. On parle beaucoup de celle de Haren, qui est relativement récente.
Il y en a d'autres à Dendermonde, etc. Donc, on va avoir l'occasion d'en parler longuement, mais quel est votre regard aujourd'hui sur la situation carcérale en Belgique ?
Alors pour moi, le monde pénitentiaire est au bout du bout du rouleau. Vraiment. Et le paradoxe incroyable, c'est que la loi de principe de 2005 sur toute la question carcérale, à l'époque, on avait dit : C'est une loi formidable.
Tout le monde disait que c'est une des meilleures lois possibles. Et on va fêter les vingt ans de la loi l'année prochaine et elle n'est toujours pas mise en vigueur dans, par exemple,
l'élément le principal qui est la création d'un plan de détention.
Je reviens au Québec. Quand vous entrez en prison au Québec, le premier jour, on commence à travailler avec vous un plan de détention.
Un plan, c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qu'on va faire, qu'est-ce qu'on va travailler avec vous pendant le temps pendant lequel vous serez détenu dans un établissement pénitentiaire.
Chez nous, on en a parlé il y a un an. On allait mettre le plan de détention en route et rien n'est encore fait. Et alors, quand moi, je préside la Commission des plaintes, je vois que la violence institutionnelle en prison est effrayante. Effrayante.
En particulier en raison de la surpopulation qui ne favorise pas.
Pas nécessairement en raison de la surpopulation, mais en raison—
Ça ne favorise pas, disons.
Ça ne favorise pas, mais moi, je suis à la prison d'Ittre où il n'y a pas vraiment une surpopulation, mais c'est tout le relationnel entre les agents pénitentiaires et les détenus est à revoir.
Il y a une violence latente qui est insupportable. Et ça tient notamment, et essentiellement d'ailleurs, à la formation des agents pénitentiaires.
On va en parler tout de suite, mais revenons donc au Québec. Donc le—
Oui.
Le lien entre alors les agents pénitentiaires et les prisonniers, comment vous le décririez ?
Il y a deux choses qui m'ont frappé au Québec, c'est d'abord que si vous voulez être directeur d'une prison, vous devez déposer un projet.
Vous devez avoir un projet pour la gestion de la prison pour laquelle vous postulez, ce qui est déjà toute une— c'est un monde par rapport à la nomination d'un directeur de prison en Belgique.
Ça, c'est la première chose. Et la deuxième chose, je vous dis, c'est qu'il y a une gestion du temps pénitentiaire qui est incroyablement plus fertile que celle que nous avons chez nous.
C'est ça. Mais spécifiquement sur la question du rapport entre les agents pénitentiaires et, voilà, vous parlez de rapports assez violents, si je comprends bien.
Oui, tout à fait.
Oui, au Québec, en comparaison, ça ressemble à quoi ?
Un exemple aussi. Par exemple, les détenus pour faits de mœurs. En Belgique, ils sont en général ostracisés à l'intérieur de la prison par un système qui fait que les détenus de droit commun considèrent que les détenus pour mœurs sont des salauds.
Voilà, c'est caricatural, mais c'est comme ça. Et donc, en général, ils font l'objet de vexations importantes.
Au Québec, tous les détenus pour affaires de mœurs se trouvent dans une aile particulière où il n'y a qu'eux. Et donc, il n'y a aucune violence qui s'exerce à l'égard des détenus pour des faits de mœurs.
Pour éviter toute forme de stigmatisation.
Pour éviter toute forme, et pour aussi permettre un travail constructif plus important que chez nous. Parce qu'en fait, il se passe rien en prison en Belgique.
Rien. Mais le nombre de fois où je me suis baladé dans la prison pour rencontrer des détenus, à 11 heures, ils dormaient parce qu'ils n'ont rien d'autre à faire.
Ouais.
Et donc...
Donc, on est loin d'un projet.
On est loin d'un projet. Il y a,
il y a absolument pas de projet sur le plan pénitentiaire
en Belgique. Alors, il y a une explication toute simple, c'est que le monde politique se fout pas mal du monde pénitentiaire puisque c'est toute façon pas électoralement porteur et donc il n'y a pas de raison de s'y intéresser.
C'est un peu méchant ce que je dis là, mais c'est à peine caricatural.
C'est, en effet, je pense qu'électoralement, plus porteur de stigmatiser cette population et d'expliquer que ce sont des déchets, qu'on s'en fiche et que, etc.
Que de parler d'un projet de transformation et de comprendre pourquoi ils sont arrivés, en sont arrivés là et qu'est-ce qu'on peut mettre en place pour, euh—
Et je me souviens—
Améliorer leur situation.
Je me souviens d'avoir eu un débat chez Eddy Caekelberghs à la RTBF avec un député MR sur les questions prison. Et ce député n'avait en tête que l'idée, il faut mettre des filets de protection pour éviter qu'on puisse
larguer avec des hélicoptères des produits toxiques ou éventuellement des évasions.
Oui.
Donc, on voyait où il en était sur le plan de la réflexion pénitentiaire, c'est-à-dire nulle part.
Oui, juste pour être clair, l'idée qu'on largue des choses en hélicoptère dans les prisons, ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on constate, on est d'accord ?
Mais non. Mais—
Où est-ce qu'il a été chercher cette idée alors ?
Je sais pas, mais je crois que c'était un moment où il y avait eu des évasions...
En France, peut-être.
Oui, ça devait être ça.
Oui, là, il y a eu des choses plus, plus spectaculaires, en effet.
Je pense que si une prison est bien gérée, il y a aucun problème de violence. Parce que tout le monde travaille dans le même esprit.
Et c'est un peu le cas en Hollande, ce qui est aussi paradoxal, c'est parce que la Hollande, c'est plus près que du Québec.
En Hollande, quand vous entrez en prison, vous êtes accueilli par l'agent pénitentiaire. Alors, c'est évidemment tout à fait hollandais, mais vous avez un café et un petit biscuit et on vous explique le fonctionnement de la prison.
On prend le temps de vous expliquer comment fonctionne la prison et on vous explique aussi que le tutoiement réciproque est autorisé.
Donc, le détenu peut tutoyer l'agent pénitentiaire et l'agent peut tutoyer le détenu. En Belgique, vous n'avez aucun accueil pénitentiaire.
L'accueil se fait, on vous met peut-être quelques documents, mais on— vous apprenez le fonctionnement de la prison par la pratique quotidienne et par les codétenus.
Mh. Parlez-moi un petit peu du profil des gardiens de prison. Qui sont ces personnes ? D'où est-ce qu'ils viennent ?
Est-ce que— on parlait de la question de la formation.
Alors, on a souvent dit que un tiers des gardiens de prison étaient des salopards, un tiers étaient des fonctionnaires qui n'avaient rien su faire d'autre que ça et un tiers étaient des agents formidables.
Et donc, dans la prison, il y a des gens formidables, des gens au moment des grèves dans les prisons, je sais, des fonctionnaires entraient à la prison à trois heures du matin pour être là avant le piquet de grève.
Donc c'est des gens qui avaient l'impression de faire un travail utile et ils voulaient faire ce travail utile.
Vous avez des gens qui sont volontiers méchants parce que la formation des agents est tout à fait insuffisante, notamment la formation à la psychologie des détenus.
Un agent pénitentiaire, par exemple, ne sait pas sentir si quelqu'un fait une décompensation psychiatrique. Il va croire que c'est de la violence alors qu'elle s'explique sur le plan psychologique.
S'ils avaient une formation plus fine, il y aurait beaucoup moins de problèmes.
Oui. Pour revenir sur le stéréotype que vous mettiez en avant, le un tiers de salopards, un tiers d'humanistes, un tiers de fonctionnaires, c'est quelque chose que vous avez pu constater ou bien c'est juste—
C'est toujours un peu caricatural, évidemment. Les chiffres ne correspondent pas à tout ça. Mais il y a,
il y a ces trois configurations de personnalité dans le personnel pénitentiaire et notamment, je le répète, par absence de formation.
Oui, oui, oui. Donc, pour revenir sur l'exemple de la prison de Haren, donc qui remplace, si je ne dis pas de bêtises, celle de Forest-Saint-Gilles.
Donc les exemples qu'on a pu entendre sont des problèmes techniques, puisque c'est une prison relativement récente et qui était plus développée que des prisons plus anciennes,
avec un système électronique, je crois, vis-à-vis d'ouverture de portes, etc.
Et il y avait la question de comment est-ce qu'on amène ces détenus au palais de justice à Bruxelles pour faire leur procès.
Et il y avait sou— il y a eu souvent, il y a encore souvent
des retards très importants et des prévenus qui devaient être à leur procès et qui, finalement, n'ont pas pu venir parce que ça n'a pas pu se faire en raison d'un problème technique vis-à-vis de,
du portail, vis-à-vis de la camionnette, vis-à-vis de— ils n'ont pas été prévenus ou des choses comme ça.
Il y a même eu un prévenu qui, à force de ne pas pouvoir assister à son propre procès, un jugement a été prononcé pour dire que dans un— dans l'État de droit, justement, ce n'est pas normal de ne pas pouvoir être jugé.
Et donc, les charges contre ce prévenu n'ont pas été retenues pour cette raison et il a été libéré.
Mais il y a deux questions principales pour Haren. D'abord, depuis le temps qu'on en parle, tout le monde était effrayé à l'idée de la distance entre la prison de Haren et le palais de justice, ce qui est une aberration.
C'est déjà une aberration puisque on a même pensé éventuellement déplacer la chambre des conseils à l'intérieur de la prison. Ce qui est—
Pour résoudre ce problème de—
Ce qui est de toute façon rendre difficile l'accès pour les magistrats, pour les greffiers à la prison plutôt que pour les détenus.
Et la deuxième question, c'est qu'on a décidé l'opérationnalité de la prison beaucoup trop tôt. Elle n'était pas prête.
Quand on a commencé à faire entrer des détenus à la prison de Haren, sur le plan technique, la prison n'était pas prête à les recevoir.
Il y avait des systèmes qui n'étaient pas prêts. On m'a raconté, une psychologue qui a été coincée pendant trois heures entre deux portes parce que les,
les— le système ne permettait pas l'ouverture de portes et elle était accompagnée d'une dizaine de détenus.
Ça s'est bien passé, mais c'est tout à fait anormal. Voilà.
Choquant, oui.
Et alors, il y a l'autre question, une troisième question au fait, qui est la déshumanisation, puisque tout se passe par informatique et il y a presque plus de contacts entre les agents pénitentiaires et les détenus.
Ce qui, dans un système pénitentiaire bien organisé, est important, puisque le contact humain entre l'agent pénitentiaire et le détenu est fondamental pour permettre la réinsertion.
Mh. On parle parfois de radicalisation encore plus importante à l'intérieur des prisons. Le portrait que vous décrivez aujourd'hui, effectivement, on peut se demander l'impact que ça peut avoir sur la santé mentale, sur le bien-être individuel.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui a été constaté ? Donc l'idée qu'on a des détenus qui
ressortent dans une situation encore pire que quand ils sont entrés, c'est-à-dire dans un état psychologique empiré et dans un état idéologique peut-être gravement empiré vis-à-vis de radicalisation possible.
Est-ce que c'est juste de dire ça ?
Ça, c'est certain. Je pense pas que les détenus sortent meilleurs qu'ils ne sont entrés, alors que c'est ça l'objectif de la prison.
C'est de faire en sorte que quand vous sortez, vous êtes meilleur que quand vous y êtes entré. Sinon, à quoi sert le travail de réinsertion ?
Il y a une deuxième question, c'est que les détenus, je vais le dire de manière la plus objective possible.
Je dirais que nonante pour cent des détenus dans la prison que je connais bien à Ittre ont un nom qui n'est pas à consonance belge.
Je vais pas aller plus loin. C'est interpellant parce que ça correspond aussi à une partie des statistiques criminelles et je comprends pas qu'on ne puisse pas s'interroger sur ce phénomène-là.
Comment se fait-il qu'il y a autant de personnes qui sont d'origine étrangère ou qui le sont encore dans le monde pénitentiaire.
J'ai une fois rencontré un monsieur, j'ai cru que c'était un visiteur de prison. Et pour vous dire l'importance de la-- visuellement, je me suis dit, c'est quelqu'un
du milieu social qui est celui de l'extérieur.
Et en fait, c'était un bourgeois, mais qui était condamné pour une lourde peine pour des faits graves. Et donc c'était, il-
Il détonnait par rapport aux physionomies, aux profils et aux physionomies habituelles. On est habitué dans les prisons.
C'est quelqu'un de très inquiétant.
Oui, oui. Je pense que pour expliquer cette observation-là, je pense que chaque parti politique aura des explications relativement différentes à droite, à gauche.
Probablement.
Mais je, voilà, je-
Oui.
On comprend là où vous situez par rapport à ça.
Vis-à-vis donc de la question de la surpopulation en prison, ce qu'on observe aussi, c'est, voilà, ça rejoint ce que vous disiez sur les criminels qui sont là pour des faits de mœurs.
Oui.
Il y a l'idée qu'il y a souvent des profils qui ne devraient pas se côtoyer, mais qui se retrouvent en promiscuité, qui finalement empirent leur situation.
On a des profils, voilà, des profils psychiatriques inquiétants et qui doivent se côtoyer alors qu'il vaudrait mieux qu'ils ne se côtoient pas.
Et donc pour répondre à ce constat de surpopulation, le ministre de la Justice a proposé l'idée de : on va en prison un mois sur deux.
Si on a une peine en dessous de dix ans, on a un congé pénitentiaire, c'est ça ?
Beaucoup se sont demandé si ce n'était pas une blague.
Oui, un canular.
Un canular. Parce qu'en termes d'organisation, c'est absolument ridicule.
Je veux dire, comment voulez-vous, d'abord, vous passez un mois à l'extérieur, vous ne savez pas travailler puisque le mois suivant, vous devez rentrer en prison.
Donc, c'était assez loufoque. Mais ça dit quelque chose de la compréhension que le ministre de la Justice a des questions pénitentiaires.
C'est comme s'il fallait régler le problème du flux de manière purement mathématique ou de manière inhumaine.
Ça donne l'impression que la question a été considérée dans un tableau Excel.
Tout à fait. Exactement. C'est exactement ce que vous dites. Mais pour parler des profils psychologiques, ce qu'on constate quand on pratique un peu le monde pénitentiaire, c'est que nombre de détenus auraient besoin d'aide psychologique.
Et pas seulement médicale.
Est-ce qu'on leur propose aujourd'hui ?
On leur propose rien, rien du tout. Et alors, par exemple, encore sur le plan médical, puisqu'on est là-dessus, la dentisterie en prison, je peux vous dire qu'avoir mal aux dents chez soi, c'est déjà difficile.
Avoir mal aux dents en prison avec l'impossibilité d'avoir rapidement un rendez-vous chez un dentiste en prison, on vous donne du Dafalgan pendant des semaines et des semaines.
Il y en a un qui attend depuis deux ans d'avoir un rendez-vous chez un dentiste. Donc ça vous dit aussi, mais quand je vous dis que si on est au bout du rouleau, c'est à tous points de vue.
Oui.
Qu'on est au bout du rouleau.
Même pour, parce que là, on touche aux droits humains, finalement.
Tout à fait.
Au-delà de l'État de droit.
C'est, c'est-
Tout à fait.
Avoir accès à la médecine, c'est...
Je dois dire que je m'attendais à entendre des témoignages assez choquants, mais celui-là, c'est...
Non, la médecine pénitentiaire, elle est d'abord en sous-nombre parce qu'il n'y a pas assez de médecins.
Ceux qui sont, enfin, je pense à la prison d'Ittre, avant, ce n'était pas le cas, mais ils sont aujourd'hui vraiment des gens qui cherchent à faire le meilleur travail possible, mais souvent avec une impossibilité absolue
de travailler concrètement.
Mh. On approche tout doucement de la fin de cet entretien. Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres points que vous voudriez aborder ?
Donc, on a parlé des différents parquets, on a parlé des prisons, on a parlé de l'exécutif. Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres aspects dont on n'a pas encore parlé ?
Non, je pense que j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour les jeunes magistrats qui travaillent aujourd'hui dans les parquets, dans les tribunaux, dans des conditions difficiles, avec, je pense, en général.
Enfin, moi, j'ai beaucoup accompagné des jeunes stagiaires judiciaires dans leur formation et je vois dans la jeune magistrature un, oui, un enthousiasme, j'espère qu'il ne sera pas étouffé par les conditions matérielles de travail.
Mh. Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qu'on observe ? C'est un découragement des jeunes magistrats qui se découragent parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à travailler efficacement.
J'ai moins le contact avec les jeunes magistrats que je n'avais il y a vingt ans, donc je ne saurais pas vraiment répondre de manière fine à votre question.
Oui. Mais là, ne serait-ce que par rapport à ce qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure vis-à-vis des burn-out, est-ce que vous savez si ça a été chiffré ?
Non, je ne pense pas qu'il y ait des chiffres certains. Mais peut-être qu'il y a... Alors, je termine positivement parce qu'il y a un métier judiciaire qui, justement, donne toute sa légitimité au travail du juge.
Parce que le juge n'est pas élu, la légitimité du juge, disait Paul Martens, président de la Cour constitutionnelle, vient de ce que sa mission est d'apaiser les conflits.
Alors, s'il y a bien un juge qui est préposé à apaiser les conflits, c'est le juge de paix. Et donc mon travail de quinze années pendant lesquelles j'étais juge de paix, je trouvais que c'était un travail formidable.
On pouvait vraiment, parce qu'on avait le temps, apaiser les conflits. Mais là aussi, l'organisation judiciaire des justices de paix tend à ne plus permettre ce travail
de résolution de conflits comme il était quand j'étais juge de paix.
Oui. En quoi est-ce que ça a évolué ? En quoi est-ce que ça s'est détérioré ?
On a diminué le nombre de justices de paix, on les a regroupées, on a augmenté le nombre de— et puis on a fonctionnarisé beaucoup de processus qui font que le travail est parfois devenu beaucoup plus administratif qu'avant.
Oui, oui. Ça, c'est quelque chose qui revient aussi à travers les secteurs, y compris dans l'enseignement.
Oui, tout à fait.
Et en plus de ça, le manque de staff-
Oui.
...qu'on évoquait. Voilà, vous évoquiez l'idée de terminer sur une note positive. Est-ce qu'il y a eu— on a beaucoup parlé de détérioration et d'empirement du paysage judiciaire en Belgique.
Est-ce qu'il y a eu des améliorations, des transformations positives qui vous ont marquées durant cette quarantaine d'années de carrière ?
Oh, je vois pas spécifiquement une amélioration. Les améliorations venaient quand on avait des chefs de corps qui étaient de qualité.
Ça, je pense que quand un procureur général était de qualité, c'était autrement agréable de travailler avec lui que quand c'était le contraire.
Donc, la responsabilité des chefs de corps, je pense au président de tribunal. Un bon président de tribunal va certainement aider ses juges à travailler beaucoup plus efficacement et dans un plus grand enthousiasme
que si le président n'est pas de grande qualité.
Mh. Et vous évoquiez également tout à l'heure l'arrivée du Conseil supérieur de la justice.
Tout à fait.
C'est peut-être, ouais, un autre exemple de— mais bon, ça date un petit peu.
Ça date un peu.
Est-ce qu'on en est là ? Est-ce que le dernier exemple positif d'une évolution significative du paysage judiciaire date d'il y a 25 ans ?
Oui et non, parce que le Conseil supérieur aussi organise les examens d'accès à la magistrature. Et donc, je pense que le Conseil supérieur a eu comme
résultat positif, en tout cas, de ne pas permettre d'entrer dans la magistrature des gens qui n'avaient pas leur place.
Sur le plan intellectuel-
Mh.
Sur le plan-
À quel profil est-ce que vous pensez quand vous dites des gens qui n'ont pas leur place ?
Des gens qui n'avaient pas la qualité intellectuelle. Ils avaient leur diplôme de droit, mais ce n'est pas pour ça qu'ils avaient de bonnes connaissances juridiques.
D'accord.
Par contre-
Comment c'est possible d'avoir un diplôme de droit sans connaissances juridiques ?
Il faut demander au professeur de droit.
OK. Donc, donc, OK. Donc, vous avez-
Il y a une évolution par le fait que—
je pense à des magistrats que j'ai côtoyés qui étaient juristes, forcément, ils avaient eu leur diplôme,
mais qui n'étaient pas de grande qualité par rapport à ceux qui sont arrivés après avoir passé les examens d'entrée dans la magistrature.
On voyait une différence.
Mh. Et donc, parce qu'on s'approche vraiment de la fin, mais le
changement important qu'on a évoqué vis-à-vis du Conseil supérieur de la justice, c'est donc aussi le fait que c'est lui qui nomme les magistrats.
Est-ce que c'est un aspect qui a pu empirer, détériorer les relations avec l'exécutif aussi ? Le fait qu'ils ont perdu ce pouvoir-là.
La grande difficulté, c'est qu'on ne sait pas qui— bon, pour le législatif, on sait, c'est le président de la Chambre.
Pour l'exécutif, c'est le Premier ministre. Pour le monde judiciaire, on ne sait pas qui peut parler au nom du monde judiciaire.
Mh.
Puisque vous avez à la fois les tribunaux, les cours d'appel et vous avez les parquets. Et donc, il n'y a pas d'instance qui est— il y a le Conseil—
non, il n'y a pas d'instance qui représente l'autorité judiciaire qui serait-
Le Conseil supérieur de la justice pourrait— bah oui, c'est un petit peu-
Mais il ne représente pas le monde judiciaire, nécessairement.
La mission de récolter les retours, les feedbacks, de mesurer l'état de santé.
Il ne représente pas le pouvoir judiciaire puisqu'il est partiellement composé de non-magistrats.
Oui. OK.
Voilà. Mais identifier un-
Il y a peut-être quelque chose à faire à ce niveau-là.
On pourrait éventuellement dire que le premier président de la Cour de cassation représente le monde judiciaire. Il est l'interlocuteur privilégié pour les deux autres pouvoirs.
Pourquoi pas ? Ça pourrait très bien s'imaginer comme ça.
C'est votre proposition-
C'est une proposition.
Que je vous donne aux législateurs. D'ailleurs, une question que j'ai envie de poser avant de quitter. Est-ce qu'un jour, vous pensez débarquer en politique ?
Puisque souvent, les juges, voilà, on évoquait le juge Claes. Il y a d'autres exemples. Je— Luc Henrard, voilà, qui est arrivé sur les listes du PS il y a quelques mois.
Est-ce qu'un jour, ce sera votre cas ?
Alors, moi, j'ai passé l'âge de ces questions-là, mais la question s'est posée quand j'étais encore magistrat suppléant.
On m'avait demandé d'être sur les listes du Parlement régional wallon. J'ai refusé parce qu'alors, je devais cesser ma fonction de juge suppléant.
Non, moi, je n'ai plus l'âge pour ça. Je trouve qu'être en politique aujourd'hui, il faut vraiment être jeune et enthousiaste.
Ah oui. Donc, on passera le message à Luc Henrard.
Oui, tout à fait.
Oui, mais donc vous continuez— malgré le fait que vous n'êtes pas sur les listes, vous continuez à travers vos interventions-
À m'intéresser au judiciaire, ça, c'est sûr.
Oui, c'est ça, oui, oui. Est-ce que vous mesurez un impact vis-à-vis de cet engagement-là ?
Un impact à propos de ?
Ben donc, vous développez, vous exposez vos idées, vous les faites connaître. Est-ce que vous remarquez que c'est quelque chose qui prend, quelque chose qui a un impact sur-
Il y a un moment où vous avez tout d'un coup, en fonction de l'âge, plutôt entrer dans le silence et laisser les jeunes s'exprimer sur les questions de justice.
Et certainement par le fait que je ne suis plus dans le monde judiciaire actif et donc je ne participe plus à des réunions avec des magistrats effectifs.
Donc, je suis tout doucement décalé. Et donc une fois qu'on est décalé, il est préférable d'entrer plutôt dans le silence.
Votre interview est une exception.
Voilà, vous dites ça devant un micro.
Voilà.
Très bien. Mais je vous remercie pour cette-
Merci pour vous aussi.
Et je vous dis à très bientôt. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
C'est déjà tout pour cet épisode de Septante Minutes Avec. J'espère que vous avez pu apprendre des choses. J'espère que ça vous a pas trop déprimé, même si franchement, il y a de quoi.
Moi, je fais partie des rares, je pense, qui ont eu leur ticket pour aller voir Oasis, donc ça va. Je suis à peu près immunisé contre tout.
Je pense que plus rien ne peut m'atteindre. Plus sérieusement, n'hésitez pas à partager vos retours vis-à-vis de cet épisode sur les réseaux sociaux.
Tous les liens sont en description ou directement par email, contact@septanteminutes.be en toutes lettres.
Je vous remercie d'ailleurs pour vos nombreux retours suite à l'épisode de bonus de cet été, en particulier vis-à-vis du nouveau site septanteminutes.be.
Il est magnifique, j'en suis très fier. Allez le voir si ce n'est pas déjà fait. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner aussi sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée, si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Et bien sûr, n'oubliez pas de laisser une note, que ce soit sur Apple Podcasts, Pocket Casts ou Spotify, toutes les plateformes qui le proposent.
C'est toujours apprécié, ça aide beaucoup le podcast. On se retrouve dans deux semaines pour un épisode qui combine psychologie sociale et politique, puisqu'on va parler de polarisation.
Je ne vous en dis pas plus. À très bientôt.